MORGAN FREEMAN: What
sees or feels presence of God?
It can alter the
course of many lives--
even change the world.
I want to know what it's like.
[music playing]
Do our traditions set us apart?
Or do they connect us in
ways we never imagined?
MAN: This is no story.
This is not a tale.
This is history.
How has it changed you?
MAN: The thing that
really sticks with me
is that unconditional love.
This is the room
of the mysteries.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Oh my.
Look at this.
WOMAN: They've decided death is
better than life with no faith.
MAN: I didn't know if
demons were real or not.
Now I do.
MAN: Your worst enemies
are within yourself.
MAN: There is one
supreme entity.
And that entity can
take many forms.
MAN: This is the space where
the living goddess lives.
Why were you chosen?
MORGAN FREEMAN: They
are God's way of showing
us how to live better lives.